if I could shoes the question you're
gonna ask somebody tomorrow yeah ask him
how they want to die you should ask
someone when the last time they talked
to their mom was if you could make a
promise to yourself to do something
scary tomorrow what would be how do you
truly do you feel like you're an honest
person what's the last thing you learned
what would it take for you to be saved
if you could only do one last thing for
the love of your life what would it be
if you could be any two animals mush
together what would they be what are you
doing tomorrow why does that last time
but you smile what is the quality to you
know your favorite childhood memory and
why what's the scariest thing you've
been asked how was your day how do you
picture yourself on your own what were
your dreams that came true how can you
pay it forward if you could change
anything in your life what would it be
give you my pondering look I would ask
what is the meaning of life what do you
think of existence it would probably be
kind of basic but if you could have
lunch with somebody dead or alive who
would it be what would you do if today
was the last day you were alive what's
the meanest thing you've ever done
are you planning on doing something kind
today or do you see yourself in two
years what's the most uncomfortable
situation you've ever been in your life
what is their best criticism or what has
their best criticism and I can enjoy
ideas ecomo what's the worst lie you
ever told and why did you tell it why
are you here oh my god does it have to
be a serious question knows I have a lot
of wacky hypothetical I'm a really big
fan of the question if you had to
replace a part of your body with an
instrument what would you replace and
why and also recently I've been asking
people how many days in a row do they
think they could eat a burrito like when
would they tap out cuz I would tap out
so soon but my parents were like no we
could do it for the rest of our lives
how did you get to where you are love
the best I'm a new with you prepare
yourself
what do you
pay about yourself is there something
you wish you could tell your mother
what's the most significant piece of
music that you've ever heard okay
I'm chasing your angel Oh me goodness
that is hard because I'm a music lover
I'm gonna say Kendrick Lamar DNA are you
happy
what what could it be like woman's last
time you ate ice cream and did you have
anything what do you think of the of
your past self are you sure this is the
path you want to take if you decided
when you want to be bowling so when was
it
it's your favorite writing instrument
why are they proud of their nation for
sure deepest and darkest fear what's
your most selfish dream what's your
greatest weakness what will they do the
rest of their lives have you ever been
in love if you could be if you were an
insect wins that would it be what is one
thing that you ret doing to your family
what's your plan like what the plans do
you have to better yourself but I could
choose a question to ask people tomorrow
are you really living when's a time when
you did it feel so much
most vulnerable moment you can choose
how you live not what you want to do for
a living how would you want to live what
do you think your purpose is did you
make somebody smile today where do they
see the world in 10 years how often do
you want to walk in someone start a
conversation but don't if you didn't get
paid to work what would you do what are
you going to do to resist why can't we
all just get along
what will you have for breakfast would
you rather play every instrument in the
world or be able to do any style of
dance you are what is your most recent
act of kindness towards a stranger what
advice would you give other people as
you've passed your life and grown up
have you become the person that you
thought you're going to be when you were
a child what are we all doing I would
have them switch roles and maybe ask you
a question or something
they're very cheesy
[Music]